♪♪
Welcome to
"Your Fantastic Mind."
I'm Jaye Watson.
This is a show where
we explore the mysteries
and the science
of the amazing human brain.
Resilience is
a positive word.
It's the capacity to recover
from difficulties,
to bounce back, but
what does resilience mean
when we are talking
about the brain?
This is a story of
a community do-gooder
who almost lost his life
to violence.
Here is his battle
to help his life
and his brain bounce back.
Honey, you're gonna be
a movie star.
Did you know that?
(laughing)
I've always been one
to help other people.
I've done tons of resumes
for people
and just help 'em--
the next step in life
to get 'em forward.
(Jaye Watson)
At 10 o'clock on the night
of October 30, 2016,
one of those people
helped by Russell Erickson
would return to
his Clarkston home.
Russell would answer the door
to the person he knew
and had helped, letting
into his home a man
who, over the next hour,
would rob and almost
beat him to death.
(Reporter)
Police say that
when they first came upon
that victim,
they weren't sure he was
going to live.
They said that
he managed to escape
through this window here.
When they found him,
he was lying
in a pool of blood
on the driveway.
I haven't repainted yet
because that's the chemical
they told us to use to clean
the blood off the walls.
It turns the walls blue.
It was a pretty
traumatic night.
The door was
punched in half,
and then he came in,
and he broke the bed.
I-- this is a different
sleigh bed now
'cause it doesn't have
the posts on it,
but he broke the posts
off of my previous bed
and just clubbed me
with 'em relentlessly
until I'd pass out,
and then, if I'd wake up,
he would beat me again
until I'd pass out again,
and I went through that
for about
an hour and 20 minutes.
(Jaye)
Erickson finally escaped
through a window, but
his attacker followed him
and continued to beat him
in his driveway
where neighbors saw
and called 911.
A police K-9 unit
captured the attacker
on a neighbor's porch.
♪♪
(Russell Erickson)
I had a traumatic brain injury.
The brain bleed was the worst
part of all my injuries.
My eye sockets were both
broken, and my nose was
badly displaced, and I had
a torn rotator cuff
on the left side,
and then I had
broken ribs
on both sides.
(Jaye)
Erickson spent four days
on life support.
(Dr. David Burke)
He had blunt trauma with
someone striking his head
repeatedly with a, um,
blunt object, so he had
bruising and bleeding
in the brain and
swelling of the brain.
And there's tearing forces
that occur, uh,
within the small neurons
or axons of the brain,
and, therefore, individual
fibers of the brain
are torn and damaged
permanently.
(Jaye)
Dr. David Burke is
the brain rehabilitation expert
who treated Erickson.
(Dr. Burke)
During that recovery mechanism,
swelling will occur.
Uh, with the swelling,
uh, comes a decrease
in oxygen to parts of
the brain that evolves
over time, and, therefore,
you can suffocate
some of the brain
in that early stages.
You can squeeze the life out of
some of the brain tissue
from the swelling because
it's got nowhere to go.
(Jaye)
Parts of the brain can die,
but Burke says
the understanding of
the regenerative capacity
of the brain
has shifted
over the years.
Take axons, the small nerves
in the brain
that send signals
to its destination,
like making
your fingers move.
When I was in med school,
we were told that's it.
They don't-- the-the axons
do not regrow.
But we now know that
the axons do regrow, um,
but probably not
in sufficient quantity
to regrow portions
of the brain
that are damaged,
and, therefore,
the reorganization
of existing tissue is
very much the recovery.
(Jaye)
Russell did not lose function
in his limbs, but
because he was beaten
all about his head,
his injury to his brain
involved many areas
that were no longer
functioning like they should.
He had attention issues
common to those with TBIs.
He had severe vertigo, sleep,
memory, and speech issues.
He could move about the world
seemingly normal,
but nothing was
as it had been before.
(Dr. Burke)
There are things we can do
to accelerate
the healing of the brain.
(Jaye)
Medications serve as
a foundation for the healing
of the brain.
They can help
those attention issues,
altered sleep cycles,
debilitating headaches,
dizziness, forgetfulness,
depression, even
thinking that feels slower--
all problems
caused by
the trauma to the brain.
(Dr. Burke)
Any problem with
forgetting mid-sentence?
When I get tired
in the afternoon,
I will have a hard time
pulling a word
out of my memory that
I'm wanting to say.
(Dr. Burke)
Okay.
(Jaye)
Medications support the brain
and the person, making intense
cognitive and physical rehab
more effective.
Three.
(Dr. Burke)
The more you attempt to do
what h-has been damaged,
uh, the more likely
the brain will reorganize.
And, in Russell's case,
he's the most motivated guy
that you'll meet.
Face the mirror.
Ready?
Step up.
Good, and back.
And turning your head
right and left five times.
(Jaye)
The work to get back
what was lost...
Excuse me.
(Jaye)
Is hard.
All right,
five more seconds.
(Jaye)
There is physical...
Gonna give you
a little more resistance.
Mm-hmm.
(Jaye)
Occupational...
And speech therapy.
You're right on with that.
You don't wanna be labeled
as a brain injured person.
Yes.
You are a person who
had a brain injury.
(Jaye)
There is vestibular therapy
to improve vertigo.
(Therapist)
And look at the red light.
Mm-hmm.
♪♪
(Jaye)
Almost two years after
the night he nearly died,
Russell has his life back.
He returned to his job at 3M
just months after the attack.
So, how is it that two people
can have the same injury,
but one will recover
better than the other?
One reason is genetics.
A great example is,
uh, the boxing careers
of Muhammad Ali
and Joe Frazier.
You know, arguably
two of the best fighters,
uh, ever, and they arguably,
um, punched each other
the same amount of time,
same amount of, you know,
trauma to each, but
Joe Frazier didn't seem
phased by it, and Muhammad Ali
got Parkinson's disease
and was, you know,
when I met him a few years ago,
unable to speak,
was having trouble walking,
uh, had really deteriorated.
(Jaye)
In patients like
Russell Erickson, there is
something else that is
harder to measure,
something that
does not show up in images
of the brain or in
measurements of the body.
I was given a little stone,
and put it in your pocket,
and every time you touch it,
you think of something
to be grateful for.
(Jaye)
He has a supply
of gratitude stones
for himself and just about
everybody he meets.
(Russell)
For the longest time,
I looked at these pictures,
and then I actually
put 'em away, so I wouldn't
start relating to
that's who I am.
(Jaye)
He put those photos away,
focusing on healing.
You back for
some more pettin'?
(Jaye)
Letting go of the trauma.
A conversation with
a police officer
just days after he was
attacked illustrates that.
(Russell)
He asked me, "How do you feel
"about this guy
who did this to you?"
And I said, "Well,"
I said, uh,
"Between you and me,
"I have to forgive him
completely and-- because I need
"all my energy for healing,
and if I hold a grudge
"against him, then that's gonna
rob me of my healing."
(Jaye)
Erickson still helps
those in need, but
he now meets them
at public places,
and his home has
a camera surveillance system.
One thing that I think is
critical is that
people stop looking
in the rear view mirror
and look ahead.
I say, you know,
you can't drive through life
if you're looking
in the rear view mirror,
and if they're always
looking at what they lost
rather than ahead
of what they can acquire,
then their recovery is slow.
I think Russell's like,
"let's go," you know?
He doesn't have rear view
mirrors in his car.
(chuckles)
He took 'em off
a long time ago.
(Jaye)
Despite all he has been through,
the man with
rocks in his pockets
and a smile on his face
will tell you
he's one of the luckiest
guys around.
You can come out on the other
side just as blessed
or more blessed even though
you go through
hard experiences.
♪♪
So, the one thing
this week is
something that could
reduce your risk
of type two diabetes,
cardiovascular disease,
premature death, stress,
even high blood pressure.
That one thing is
getting out in nature.
Scientists looked at
global data from 140 studies
involving 290 million people
from 20 different countries,
including the U.S.,
looking to see
if nature provides
a legitimate health boost.
They analyzed the health
of people with
the least access to nature
with those with the most,
and those with the most,
well, they had
lower incidences of several
conditions and diseases.
They also had
lower blood pressure,
lower heart rate,
lower stress.
They even slept longer.
One of the more interesting
findings is that being in nature
dramatically reduces
people's levels
of salivary cortisol,
a physiological marker
of stress.
This is one treatment that
you don't need
a prescription
from your doctor.
It is the most famous dance
to come out of Argentina.
Tango-- a partner dance
that emphasizes
vibrant and
playful movement
and lots of improvisation.
But tango is also
becoming known as
a powerful tool for patients
with Parkinson's disease.
This story is about
a Parkinson's brain on tango.
♪♪
I just saw her, and she just
did somethin' to me.
Somethin' just went ca-clunk.
(laughing)
(Jaye)
The disco was Christy's
in Cincinnati, Ohio,
and the woman who
made something go ca-clunk
inside Lee Reaves
was Jere.
(Lee Reaves)
I kept begging her
to marry me, marry me,
marry me, marry me,
and she kept saying,
"No, no, no."
(Jaye)
The "yes" came 34 years ago.
And we danced our way
through our marriage.
(laughing)
(Jaye)
That was before
Lee, a mechanical engineer,
had a stroke.
It was before Jere,
a registered nurse,
noticed a change
in her body.
I didn't really feel anything
going on
except just a twitching
in my pinky,
sorta like a-- like
a tick you might get
in-in the face.
(Jaye)
That twitching pinky led to
a diagnosis of
Parkinson's disease.
(Lee)
It was kinda devastating
at first, you know?
Well, I dunno
if it's devastating.
It was just somethin'-somethin'
to-to get your arms around.
(Jaye)
Doctors don't know what causes
Parkinson's disease,
a slowly progressive
neurological disorder
that is caused by
degeneration of neurons
in the brain.
Dr. Stewart Factor is
the Director of the Movement
Disorders Program
at Emory Brain Health Center.
The main neurons that die
are dopamine neurons,
and, uh, all the treatments
that we have--
nearly all the treatments
are for replacement
of dopamine in the brain.
(Jaye)
Among its many jobs,
dopamine impacts
brain processes
that control movement.
It's defined by
motor symptoms-- tremor,
stiffness, slowness, walking
and balance problems.
(Jaye)
It's been ten years
since Jere's diagnosis.
(Jere)
I'm doing pretty good.
I think there's-- it's
advancing a little bit now.
It's getting harder to, like,
follow the lines.
(Jaye)
She still paints,
the latest a family tree.
I'm going to put names
on the big leaves
of the different
family members.
Will you tie a knot
in there?
Yeah.
Thank you.
I sew, and I can't
do as neat a job now.
Uh, writing is terrible.
You can barely read it.
And my voice
has been modulating
like almost not there.
(Jaye)
Walking has replaced running.
Last year, Jere broke her hip
in a fall.
Despite the struggles,
there is one constant.
(Instructor)
All right, everyone,
when you get a chance, grab
a partner and start dancing.
(Jaye)
It's less nightclub
and more high school gym,
but make no mistake.
The gym at the VA in Atlanta
is tango central.
Five, six, ready, and...
T-A-N-G-O
and T-A-N-G-O.
(Jaye)
Parkinson's patients are
paired with volunteers,
from grad students
to dancers
in the community.
Am I messin' up
too much?
No, we're doing great.
(Lee)
I like it-- it's fun.
You know, you meet a lotta--
a lotta cool people.
(Jaye)
Lee and Jere have come
twice a week
for a few years,
not just because it's fun,
but because
it is helping Jere.
(Jere)
I've noticed a difference.
It organizes, uh,
movement better,
and it-- with the steps
for tango,
you have to switch,
uh, your thinking.
(Jaye)
Emory Assistant Professor
of Medicine
and VA Research Scientist
Dr. Madeleine Hackney
is the tango instructor.
T-A-N-G-O.
(Jaye)
She is also a former
professional dancer.
(Dr. Madeline Hackney)
And I knew that I was
especially interested
in the way the brain
controls movement.
(Jaye)
It's an unconventional approach
with an unconventional
lead scientist.
But what the tango can do
for people with Parkinson's
is significant.
I had this idea that
dance might be
something that could help
people to move better
and overcome various
injuries, because
dancers think about
movement so deeply.
(Jaye)
There had already been
some research on
the effects of tango.
There was one, um,
that had shown that
frail older adults,
if they participated in
Argentine tango,
had improved
in complex walking tasks
afterwards, comparison
to a-an exercise control group,
and so that was like
a little piece of--
kernel of evidence that,
okay, tango, interesting.
And then there was another
piece of evidence
that showed that
while people were lying
in a positron emission
tomography, a PET scanner,
if they were doing
tango-like movements
to a very rhythmic beat,
there was increased
activation in the putamen
of the basal ganglia,
which is the part
of the brain that is
most impacted by
Parkinson's disease.
(Jaye)
Dr. Hackney's first
pilot study on tango for
Parkinson's patients
was 12 years ago.
She modified the dance
and the steps to make it
safe yet hopefully effective.
(Dr. Hackney)
First of all, we looked at
20 hours of tango
over a 12-week period
versus 20 hours
of a chair exercise class,
which is the traditional class
that was offered at the time.
Improved balance
and gait parameters,
so it improved
balance and walking.
(Jaye)
Hackney's study showed that
after the class, tango dancers
with Parkinson's
were able to walk further,
faster, and longer
than before the class.
Standard clinical motor exams
to measure balance
also showed improvements
that were also retained.
So, does it have to
be tango?
Well, Hackney says that
the fox trot and the waltz
are just as effective,
with one difference...
this.
Tango patients were able
to get up from
a chair and walk
more easily
and quickly.
That is no small feat
in a disease
marked by mobility issues.
Hackney says the improvisation
that tango allows
is another plus
for patients.
Functional MRIs, which look at
blood flow in the brain
to detect areas of activity,
are now being used
to learn what brain network
scenarios change
after dance rehabilitation
in people with
Parkinson's disease.
There is no definitive answer
yet, but Hackney thinks
the findings will confirm
what she believes.
(Dr. Hackney)
Dance itself is a form of
cognitive rehabilitation.
When people dance,
and in our--
especially in the tango,
they have to
use their brains in a very,
very particular way.
They have to
remember things.
understand timing.
They have to understand
how to put a movement to music,
and it, in a way, it's
a form of cognitive training.
And I think, if we can see that
on-- in our brain,
that'd be really cool.
(Jaye)
It's not just that it works.
It's that this class
makes people feel good.
(Dr. Hackney)
It's not about people being
patients in the room.
It's just about people being
people together
and enjoying
something together.
(Jaye)
For one couple, it continues
what began in a Cincinnati disco
all those years ago.
Dance cannot undo the loss,
but it can restore
confidence and connection
step by step.
♪♪
We all have deadlines.
Whether it's a work project,
emails to return,
laundry to get done.
So, then why do we stalk
high school friends
on Facebook for two hours?
Why do we go to the fridge
for the fifth time
thinking we'll see something
we didn't see before?
The reason?
Procrastination.
And here's one definition:
the voluntary delay
of a task we intend to do
and know that we'll suffer
as a result.
In a study in the journal
"Psychological Science,"
they've shown that
procrastination tends
to run in families.
It is in our very genes.
But, even if we don't
inherit it, most of us
tend to put stuff off,
and that's because
we care more about
the present than the future.
That's the way we're wired
as human beings.
The present is now.
Eh, I'll worry about now.
So, here's advice for next time
you're procrastinating.
Take a step back from
your life and look at
the big picture,
what you've been putting off,
going back to school,
exercising, laundry.
And then comes
the hard part.
Do it.
Now, to something
all of us do
and probably rarely
consider: blinking.
Scientists say we blink
on average 15 to 20 times
per minute.
That's 1,200 times per hour
and 28,800 times per day.
But, for thousands of people,
the blinking gets
out of control, leaving them
functionally blind.
The rare neurological disorder
is called blepharospasm.
Here's one woman's story.
(Nilda Rendino)
You know, when you're young,
you're young, and
the world's wonderful,
and nothing, uh, nothing bad
is gonna happen.
(Jaye)
They are the pleasures of life
in retirement.
Although I've always--
I've worn glasses
since I was in
fourth grade, so, I mean,
I've-- in that sense,
I've had eye limitations.
(Jaye)
A spontaneous walk
on a brisk spring day.
(Nilda)
Everything starts from prayer.
But the-the print is a little
bigger on this one.
I could handle this one.
(Jaye)
A leisurely discussion
of a well-loved book.
"It is not how much we do
that is pleasing to God
"but how much love
we put into the doing."
That's nice.
(Jaye)
For Nilda Rendino,
books, and walks, and even
watching TV
are newfound gifts
after 25 years
spent like this.
This is DYS number 3100
enroll-enrolled
at Emory University
on September 20, 2017.
(Jaye)
This was Nilda when she arrived
at Emory Brain Health,
a 75-year-old woman who
had been living her life
with her eyes closed
most of the time.
(Dr. Hyder Jinnah)
Um, and so it can be
extremely disabling.
Um, in fact, when it gets
bad enough, we call--
we say that people can be
functionally blind
because they can't
keep their eyes open.
(Jaye)
What is happening to
Nilda's eyes and face
in this video, the spasms,
the blinking, the eyes
that won't open, is
due to a condition
called blepharospasm.
Emory Brain Health's
Dr. Hyder Jinnah.
In blepharospasm, the muscles
surrounding the eyes
are over-contracting,
so they are doing
more than they should,
but the problem
is not in the muscles.
The problem is actually
in the brain's way of
controlling your blinking.
Somewhere along the line,
the brain sends signals
for your blinking
that are too much.
They're too exaggerated
in some way,
and so you blink longer,
you spasm, uh,
and your eyes may blink closed,
and they don't
open for you like, uh,
in Nilda's case.
(Jaye)
Nilda was diagnosed
20 years ago.
That was after six years
of going doctor to doctor,
after giving up
driving, and reading,
and even watching TV.
And I was lucky because
people who went through
that same situation
were often told
that it was
in their head
and not meaning that
it was neurological
but that they were--
you know, had
psychological problems.
Some people were
hospitalized
for their, um,
mental problems.
(doctor)
Next thing
I want you to do--
(Jaye)
A rare condition without
a known cause or cure,
blepharospasm usually begins
sometime after the age of 50,
affecting 40,000
to 50,000 in the U.S.
with twice as many
as that
thought to be misdiagnosed
or undiagnosed.
When she finally found out
what she had 20 years ago
from a doctor up North,
Nilda remembers when
he told her the treatment.
And he said, "Well,
you get, uh, injections
around your eyes,"
and I said,
"That's the good news?"
The treatment
is botulinum toxin,
and the way it works
is by, um, getting into
the areas where the nerves
control the muscles,
and what it does is,
it slows the nerves down.
It doesn't really
paralyze them.
Um, it slows them down
so that their communication
with the muscles they control
is less forceful, if you will.
(knocking)
I tell patients that it's
like a local muscle relaxer.
Um, that's a little
bit simplified,
but that's really
what it's doing.
It's working locally to calm
the overactive muscles.
(Jaye)
Botox is the most well-known
brand of botulinum toxins.
While injections help
the spasms, for 20 years,
Nilda's eyes still stayed
closed most of the time
until her husband, Ron,
drove her to see Dr. Jinnah
from their home
in North Carolina.
She has also a feature
of blepharospasm
that maybe only 10%
of the patients have,
and that's called
apraxia of eyelid opening.
The eyes close, and then they
won't open by themselves,
and the reason for that is
because there's a spasm
in the skinny muscle
of your eyelid
that goes
right across here,
and if that spasms
while the eyes are closed,
it can't roll up
over your eyeball.
(Jaye)
A few months ago,
Jinnah changed the way
she had been injected
and included Nilda's eyelids.
The results have
been life-changing.
And it's been,
like, unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
My neighbors, who are used
to seeing me going around
with a visor and
sunglasses all the time,
didn't know I had
eyes, you know?
They said,
"Oh, your eyes are open."
I said, "Yes,
my eyes are open."
(Jaye)
We were with Nilda
three months after
her newly altered
injection plan.
The results were
beginning to wear off.
I notice that
your eyes are closing
as this light is on you.
What impact does it have?
If lights, bright lights,
are on my eyes,
you know, they-they
will close.
It's not just a blink.
They close.
I'm having problems
keeping my eyes open
because of the light.
(Jaye)
TV is becoming
problematic, again.
I'm not really, you know,
able to keep them open
long enough to follow
the-the story.
♪♪
(Jaye)
At her visit, Nilda has
big news for the doctor.
Um, I drove a couple of
times in the neighborhood.
Um, I--
Is that a new
thing for you?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
(Jaye)
There's an exam.
I mean, I can see
that you have
a little bit of
extra blinking.
It's not too bad.
I see that some of the blinks
are a little bit slow,
and the eyes don't
wanna open sometimes.
(Jaye)
Then the injections.
You ready?
(Nilda)
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
I always do
the eyelid first.
(Jaye)
Which Nilda says
don't hurt that much.
(Nilda)
No, not really.
I mean, you-- obviously,
you feel it going in,
but, you know,
I haven't had surgery,
um, so that's not
an issue,
and some people it hurts more
than others for some reason.
(Jaye)
And then she's finished.
All right, well, let's plan
for next time, then.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna
get rid of this.
(Jaye)
Injections and an almost
four-hour drive
every three months
is not a cure,
but it's a big
quality of life boost,
and it certainly gives
new meaning to the phrase
eyes wide open.
It's, yeah, it's-it's been
a great three months,
and we're going on
another cruise,
and I wanna be
doing well.
(laughing)
You-you know that this
is something that you're
gonna live with
for the rest of
your life.
Well, this is it.
This is great.
♪♪
So, we know that
parts of the brain
aren't talking to each other
like they should
in people with
blepharospasm.
Hopefully, research will lead
to more effective treatments
for this lifelong disorder.
As for Nilda,
well, she and her husband
went on a cruise.
She reported back to us
that she enjoyed and saw
all the beautiful sights
along the way.
After years spent in darkness,
it was an incredible gift.
That's gonna do it
for us this week.
We'll see you next time
on "Your Fantastic Mind."
♪♪